entry one
i didn't think it was possible to love a
laptop as much as i loved this thing
we've been through so much
this dent here from when i dropped you
down the stairs remember
you were great but now your screen looks
like an old tv your bezel is well fat
and if i see the rainbow ball one more
time
it's so hard to say goodbye
entry two
well this keyboard is different what did
ray's keys do to you apple
though i do like the bounce of these
sounds like i'm writing something very
important
oh the screen is beautiful
this one looks nice too and a bit like a
giant unibrow
i really do like the design definitely
thinner and lighter than the old macbook
pro of course that's because every port
i need has been replaced with usbc
finally a fingerprint sensor
damn that sure beats typing in a
password
entry three
packing for work is a whole new
experience when all your important ports
are taken away one dongle if i want to
use my monitor one for plugging in my
old usb peripherals and a cord to plug
in my iphone
browser good news dongle's double as dog
toys bad news 80 dog toys
entry four
i'm really excited to get to work every
job is better with a new laptop nice
that these new usbc thunderbolt ports
connect to my thunderbolt display
performance on the 13-inch pro really
doesn't feel all that different than the
older macbook pro though alright let's
talk about this touch bar it's cool for
inserting emojis and scrubbing through
video and music but i don't really use
it that often a lot of these options are
faster with a keyboard shortcut and i
miss the old physical keys
entry 5
i can fit most of my lunch on this
trackpad here's how i picture the
conversation going at apple mac team we
refuse to put touch screens on max
tim cook then make the touchpads the
size of alabama
entry six
late to another meeting joanna nice of
you to join us sorry
now seems like a great time to figure
out apple's laptop pricing puzzle
eighteen hundred dollars for this one
fifteen hundred dollars for this one
with no touch bar
and thirteen hundred dollars for the old
macbook pro
my head hurts
did you get all that
nope
good
entry seven coffee shop
just met a friend for coffee he asked me
so it kind of seems like apple's falling
behind microsoft right
is the touch bar revolutionary no is
this a great reliable laptop yes
entry eight
okay new macbook pro i like you a lot
but i'm also very torn the old macbook
pro is just as fast has the same battery
life and more ports and costs less
you're both great macbook air
replacements
just know this i don't love you
not yet